Endurance?
Yes! My brother said your endurance
doesn't change when you become a Mask.
So if you focus on defense first
and exhaust the enemy's energy,
you'll be at an advantage.
Great, all according to plan.
I can win. I'm stronger now.
I'm so happy I can help Honjo out!
Mayuko, I'm so sorry.
You got this!
This is my chance!
This is for my family!
-What?
-Stay back!
Damn you.
Oh, dear.
Seems like she's getting pretty tired.
All right!
Ein won't make it much longer.
Okay, then.
I'll take out her right arm!
This is it.
It's your turn, Zwei!
You fools!
You thought Ein was
the only Mask I could control?
-Zwei.
-Zwei!
What?
She saw right through my strategy?
That dumb-looking girl?